the last year or so has taken a real
toll on my mental health
as i'm sure it has for lots of people
and if you're subscribed to this channel
or you're watching this video chances
are you've turned to games
for some comfort it's clear that games
can have a positive
effect on our mental health but does it
matter which games we're playing
personally speaking since the pandemic
began i've spent hundreds of hours
playing
securo bloodborne the dark souls series
and demon souls and it's given me plenty
of comfort but
i don't really know why what is it about
these
intense bleak games that i found so
soothing
when i could have been playing something
like animal crossing or minecraft
now as someone who's only got a very
basic understanding of psychology that's
a difficult question for me to answer
so i got in touch with alexander chris
he's a psychotherapist
and author of the gaming mind a book
that looks at why we play
games and the positive impact that games
can have on those who play them
i've played games since i was very young
child it was late in my training when i
started to
become aware of how many young people
were presenting to the clinics and
hospitals where i was working
where gaming was a big part of their
presentation a big part of their lives
so i started to research and write
more about gaming from the perspective
of a
mental health professional of a
psychologist though the gaming mind was
written prior to the pandemic the timing
couldn't have been better
video games have remained a growth
industry over the last year with studies
reporting that 62
of adults played some form of video game
in 2020.
more people are playing games than ever
before and with that comes the potential
for people to develop their own
positive relationships to games so does
it matter what they're playing
you know there were a few games like
animal crossing being a very obvious one
that
had such a serendipitous launch it was
sort of almost
like exactly what would be called for at
the onset of a global pandemic
i think depending on the individual and
what they're dealing with
you know i've seen people take such
solace in it i've also known
patients in the past year who picked up
animal crossing and found it
so anxiety provoking like the last thing
they wanted to do was like pay back a
loan
from my perspective it sort of starts
with the person and then
moves on from there to the game games
create this opportunity
for people to kind of explore themselves
and their relationships
and what that actually means for a
person is very particular not only to
the game but to
them right their own psychology so what
exactly is it that i am getting out of
playing the souls games i mean
at this point we should probably address
the elephant in the room which is
they're [ __ ] hard it's 12 years since
the release of the original demon souls
and in that time the game and its
successors have had a profound
impact on video games leading to a
nascent genre of souls likes and a
cottage industry of challenge run
streamers and
husky voiced lore diving youtubers
invariably these games contain grand
bleak worlds opaque stories
and nightmarish creatures to battle they
are complex and strange games
and yet for the most part if you ask
someone what they think of when they
think of a souls game
it's that they are difficult
in his book alexander discusses a
patient who finds comfort in playing
fallout 4
on the punishingly difficult survivor
mode so i asked him if any research has
been conducted into the possible
benefits
of playing hard games as that's my
knowledge not been specifically
researched
but um you know is is worthy of it
especially given
the at this point now enduring
popularity of games that are regarded as
brutally difficult
there is a real validation of
the defeat right that is part of the
experience games definitely lend
themselves to
experiences of mastery and it can
certainly bring a lot of satisfaction
and people are feeling frustrated or
confined in their
lives especially because you know you
can accomplish things in games that are
a lot easier in games than in real life
you can swing a sword you can
slam dunk a basketball right things that
most people can't
do i think for a lot of people
those kinds of experiences can really be
a kind of compromise right between
the desire to feel competent and
accomplished
and like you've really done something
that not everyone could do
but also having to deal with the very
real frustrations that can exist in
people's
lives outside of games so what does all
this mean exactly
basically that in a time when we're all
feeling such a profound loss of control
over the direction of our lives it's
perfectly natural that we would turn to
video games to regain it and
particularly games that offer
such a sense of control and achievement
games like dark souls also
you get to swing a massive old big bit
of wood around
so there's that on a more personal note
i see playing these games as a kind of
mindfulness exercise
if you're not familiar mindfulness is a
kind of meditation which involves
bringing your attention to the present
moment rather than ruminating on things
in the past
or the future traditionally it involves
more familiar forms of meditation
like focusing on breathing or the
sensations of your immediate
surroundings
as someone who's had treatment for
depression and anxiety in the past this
traditional kind of mindfulness
has been recommended to me on more than
one occasion but i am
dreadful at it i am an anxious
distracted person and
i've tried long walks i've tried deep
breathing yoga
meditation being mindful but
my mind is always racing and some of
these things work
not always consistently though but one
thing over the past year that i have
noticed does work for me is playing the
souls games
because of their difficulty these games
tend to require a high level of
attention
in most cases you can't even pause the
game in a way i think they function as a
kind of
attention trap for me it's hard to sit
there worrying about the state of the
world when there's a boss the size of a
house
running at you it's hard to feel
distracted or have the desire to look at
your phone when you're working through a
game environment that is so
actively hostile because of all this i
think it quiets the part of my brain
that is usually filling my thoughts with
worries
now i am very aware that not everyone
will get this from playing these games
and i want to be clear that
while this works for me i'm in no way
suggesting that playing these games
is a blanket cure for anyone else's
depression
or anxiety in fact a lot of you probably
have
the opposite relationship to these games
and if that's the case you might have
more
in common with alexander than you do
with me
i played bloodborne briefly and
um didn't get very far but other than
that the only souls game i ever played
was demon souls and i was playing it in
the context
of a transition that was happening in my
professional life i was feeling guilty
about
some of the choices i was making in my
professional life i was leaving
in particular one patient behind i found
it to be this
incredibly maddening experience but i
played it a lot
during that period for a long time so
for me
how i came to understand that in
retrospect was that actually at that
time in my life i was looking for
something
uh kind of masochistic by the time i was
done with demon souls i was almost like
done with video games for a while like i
just was so fed up
i think that in some ways is so
illustrative of games right the two
people
playing the same game having totally
diverse and psychological experiences
that really speak to
who they are and what they're dealing
with as someone who plays these games
it's hard to deny that it feels great to
take down a boss you know many people
are gonna struggle with the series seems
to elicit the sense of communal pride
and accomplishment that you rarely see
in other games perhaps because every
player has been through the same
highs and lows there's a sense of a
community working through challenges
together
following the discovery of a locked door
in the ps5 remake of demon souls
thousands tuned in to watch distortion 2
become the first person in the world
to open it it's a series that lets you
share in other people's gutting losses
and glorious victories whether it's
other flunking a no hit run on boss
number 41 of 41
or three idiot friends beating dark
souls
on a transatlantic flight
so yeah they're difficult games and it
feels good when you beat them but
i don't think that's all there is to it
despite how difficult and intense they
are
the soulsborne games is something that
people turn to as a kind of
comfort to help them cope with mental
health difficulties
and i think despite how bleak
and oppressive the games are
a big part of that is to do with their
tone
to some extent the souls games feel like
games for our time
they meet you on your level everything
in the game is bleak everyone is sad
hopeless given the situation we've all
found ourselves in the last year
is pretty resonant now i absolutely love
mario games for example but when i'm
feeling down
i don't always want mario grinning at me
i want a character
a situation a world that reflects how
i'm feeling back at me
much in the same way that it's sometimes
cathartic to listen to sad music when
you're feeling sad
this melancholia extends to the
non-playable characters who tend to fall
into archetypes across the series
a crestfallen warrior a clumsy oaf
unable to live up to his idea of heroism
a determined but ultimately doomed
adventurer
they are invariably people who have felt
the impact of this world
someone that speaks to a loss
anxiousness and depression
in a way that can reflect your mood in
doing so they become a measuring stick
for your growth
as you progress through the game we
unkindled are worthless
can't even die right at the core of
understanding oneself is the process
of symbolizing what we go through with
language right and putting words to
feelings the crestfallen warrior or the
sort of archetype right
is saying what at least some aspect of
the player is thinking
there's no salvation here you'd have
done better to rot in the undead asylum
there can be something very relieving
in hearing one's experience reflected
concisely with words right and and in
that way feeling less alone
even though this is not another human
player it's an npc
just um hearing that somebody else
agrees on some level like
this is never going to work out hearing
it voiced and expressed then gives it
a name and a face right and it's
something that you can work with
gives the player permission to be
feeling hopeless
as opposed to suggesting that the player
should be
progressing well and feeling really good
about it and
uh if they have doubts that they'll make
it to the end that's their problem
but we're talking true legends
with the metal to link the fire we're
not fit to lick their boots
now i'm well aware that a lot of what
i've talked about in this video could
sound a bit like pseudoscience but
thinking about this stuff can have a
real impact on people's lives
part of alexander's goal through his
work is to help his patients
take the self-esteem benefits that they
get from playing games
and apply them to their day-to-day lives
outside of games
put simply one of the things that makes
it hard for someone to kind of transfer
their skills and self-esteem from a game
into
the rest of their life is that we're
conditioned to believe that
games are not relevant and important to
the rest of life so as a psychotherapist
you know my
the primary kind of technique that i use
we can call it that
is that if a patient plays games or
mentions games i just take them
seriously
right i'm curious about it like i would
be about anything else they might bring
into a session and it's uh it still
doesn't cease to surprise me
how novel that typically is for the
individual
i don't think there's anything to fear
in coming to a deeper appreciation of
our relationship with games i really
think we only have
benefits right only only gains can come
from
being more open and curious about why we
love games so much
despite how hard they are and despite
the bleak worlds they present i can
totally see why playing these games is a
kind of comfort blanket
they are repeatable learnable rhythmic
they are
unchanging and fixed in a time when so
much has been uncertain
they offer an opportunity to work
towards satisfying and rewarding goals
and might hold up a kind of mirror to
how you're feeling
they offer the chance to feel like part
of a community and sharing other
people's triumphs
and disasters they are everything we
love about video games
now you may hate the souls games and
that is absolutely fair they are clearly
not for everyone and if you've made it
this far into the video and that is the
case then
thank you so much for watching this has
clearly been a very personal video for
me to make
but hopefully something of what i've
said has resonated with you too
maybe there is a game or a series that
has given you some comfort over the past
12 months or
so i hope that is the case let me know
in the comments
down below if you have enjoyed this
video then subscribe so we can make more
content like this and maybe drop us a
like too
and in the meantime be safe don't go
hollow
but there is something greatly
comforting about that flame
it seems to fulfill something very
precious
deep within the soul something
[Music]
essential
[Music]
you